les collégiens de nains sur Beuvron ont
un établissement flambant neuf sa
particularité c'est un bâtiment à
énergie positive avec chaufferie
biomasse et panneaux solaires financé
par le Conseil départemental de
Loir-et-Cher le montant des travaux
s’élève à 13 millions d'euros elle aime
chapelet avec Romainville
24 le collège Louis Pergaud à
Neung-sur-Beuvron n'aura plus du tout
cette physionomie les préfabriqués en
béton construit en 1967 vont
progressivement faire place à un
bâtiment flambant neuf et surtout
écologique ce jour-là les murs en bois
constitué d'une isolation en paille sont
d'ailleurs installés de la paille de blé
un déchet agricole qui s'avère être un
excellent isolant thermique
de nos ateliers on va la récupérer
directement dans le champ après l'avoir
vérifier bien entendu on cherche à
apporter un maximum de matériaux
biosourcés dans le bâtiment
et la paille a un bilan de gaz à effet
de serre négatif donc il réduit d'autant
la production globale de gaz à effet de
serre d'un bâtiment
2900 m² vont progressivement sortir de
terre de niveau afin de ne pas dépasser
la cime des arbres et se fondre dans le
paysage un investissement de 13 millions
d'euros financés par le Conseil
départemental de Loir-et-Cher une
restructuration complète qui se veut
avant tout et co-responsable ici sur le
chantier de nain on a des constructions
en bois l'isolation en paille on va
utiliser la terre crue on va produire de
l'électricité on va voilà on va utiliser
des peintures à base d'algues avec des
pigments naturels ici on est sur des
bâtiments qui sont faits pour être
stables au feu qui vont contenir le feu
si jamais il y avait un incendie on
travaille plus la pérennité par rapport
à l'humidité l'isolation thermique le
confort il y aura moins de sensations de
chaud et de froid dans le bâtiment
lancé en avril 2022 alors que les élèves
étudient toujours juste à côté ce
premier collège du futur ne sera sans
doute pas le dernier